[Musique]
vivre vous êtres vivants telle est la
question quelle est la différence entre
être vivant et vivre parmi vous qui
pensent être vivant quand même qu'ils
pensent vivre pas mal être vivant c'est
une notion biologique on dit d'un
organisme qu'il est vivant c'est rempli
cinq critères bien précis
il n'est il grandit il se nourrit il se
reproduit et finalement il meurt et
vivre alors qu est ce que c est ce que
c'est un synonyme d'être vivant ou est
ce que c'est quelque chose d'autre
est ce que c'est une notion qui qui
changent en fonction des années des
personnes d expérience pour moi c'est
clair il ya plusieurs définitions à 10
ans par exemple
vivre c'est être une graine qui sort de
terre c'est vouloir tout découvrir
c'est passé des heures à dessiner à
table à son bureau à construire des
robots géants qui se transforme en
voiture ou en avion céder après midi à
faire des gâteaux avec sa grand-mère
raquer le saladier avec les doigts car
aimanté fois avec la langue c'est
regarder goldorak albator capitaine flam
à la télé de mercredi après midi et le
week-end apprend passer en boucle et des
cassettes vidéo de star wars indiana
jones
retour vers le futur même quand on les
connaît par coeur c'est elle à l'école
entraînant un peu des pieds parce qu'on
est timide et qu'on a pas beaucoup
d'avis et que de toute façon rentrer à
la maison si on n'a pas la meilleure
note
ce n'est jamais assez bien
c'est lire des tonnes de bandes
dessinées s'allonger sur son lit pour
rêver et s'inventer des univers
fantastique dans lequel on est le plus
fort on ne le héros c'est aussi vouloir
grandir un peu trop vite essayer de se
rebeller mais juste un petit peu de peur
de se prendre une bonne raclée qui
finira de toute façon pas retomber à 20
ans vivre ces arbustes qui grandit c'est
devient adulte tout en gardant un peu de
son âme d'enfant c'est sortir de sa
chrysalide et se sentir maître du monde
c'est être avide d'expériences de
découverte de nouveautés
c'est croquer la vie à pleines dents
sans se soucier du lendemain
c'est rigoler faire la fête
aller en boîte faire des voyages c'est
se réveiller le matin sur une plage à
barcelone après une soirée mousse bien
arrosée faire des rencontres faire des
conquêtes
si vivre ses premières grandes histoires
d'amour mais aussi ses premières
désillusions et ses premiers gros
chagrin
livre à 20 ans c'est aussi vouloir
devenir pilote comme mavericks dans top
gun et finalement finir à la fac à cause
d'un problème aux yeux alors c'est faire
des études sans savoir vraiment pourquoi
se perdre un peu en route et finir par
devenir ingénieur comme maman et papa
ce qui nous amène à la vie à 30 ans 30
ans et la fleur de l'âge
trente ans c'est avoir toujours 20 ans
dans sa tête mais avec plus d'expérience
et de maturité
c'est surtout ne plus penser uniquement
à soi c'est fonder une famille avoir de
magnifique bébé avant des amis en or sur
lequel on peut compter
habiter dans une belle maison et avoir
une bonne situation
c'est ça la vie à 30 ans bon il ya aussi
deux ou trois petites choses qui
fonctionnent pas très bien c'est un
détail mais allez je vous en parle mais
parce que c'est 30 ans c'est le temps
des questions
pourquoi est-ce que je passe mes
journées sur un ordinateur pourquoi est
ce que mes chefs ne reconnaissent pas la
qualité de mon travail je suis
insatisfait
alors plutôt que de me poser les bonnes
questions et d'essayer de chercher des
réponses
je me rappelais plus bel habit de super
victimes
ai je choisi la solution la plus facile
la fuite comme forrest gump
je me mets à courir cours forrest la
cour courir au début c'est un vrai
plaisir c'est envie de me dépasser de
repousser mes limites
alors je cours 10 km puis 20 puis des
marathons et je continue et j'enchaîne
jusqu'à la blessure grave
je passe à la peinture à la photographie
je gagne les concours je fais des
expositions je fais le maximum pour
réussir et pour que mes efforts soient
reconnus mais je suis toujours
insatisfait je vis le syndrome de
l'imposteur
c'est ça la vie à 30 ans mais
heureusement de l'extérieur c'est une
vraie réussite
à l'intérieur cependant je suis tout le
temps stressé
est-ce que c'est génétique psychologique
une idée une tension une pensée
normalement le stress prévient d'un
danger à court terme
ils nous aident à réagir efficacement
mais à long terme il exacerbe les
émotions il génère des tensions
physiques et mentales débilitante et
lorsque la soupape de sécurité explose
la fatigue la colère et la dépression
apparaissent en 2019
quarante pour cent des travailleurs
français de 30 à 50 en sont
régulièrement victimes de stress l'
american medical association affirme
aujourd'hui que le stress est la cause
principale de plus de 60% des maladies
et des affections incluant le cancer et
les maladies cardiaques
c'est plus que la cigarette et le
cholestérol
alors oui le stress est aujourd'hui un
fléau qui nous touche tous plus ou moins
et qui pèsent sur notre santé mais à 30
ans la santé c'est important
j'ai plutôt envie de parler de la vie à
40 ans vivra 40 ans s'est passé quatre
heures par jour en me baladant à me
balader dans la nature à sentir le
soleil sur ma peau à m'extasier du
spectacle et des feuilles mortes qui
tombent des arbres en hiver c'est faire
des changements d'alimentation essayer
tout un tas de médecine naturelle
tout ce qui peut m'aider tout ce qui
peut aider mon corps allait bien c'est
d'avoir une femme merveilleuse qui
s'occupe qui gère tout d'une main de
maître qui s'occupe bien des enfants et
aussi de moins c'est avoir une famille
et des amis qui sont présents et un
sentiment de vivre enfin je me sens bien
je me sens léger je ne travaille plus
plus de stress une réelle délivrance
c'est un peu comme les grandes vacances
à l'époque du lycée
un vrai retour aux sources mais vivre à
40 ans
c'est aussi une tumeur censé être
bénigne qui est en fait un cancer rare
et agressif
ce sont des cycles de chimiothérapie
mené tambour battant pour essayer de
prendre la maladie de vitesse ce sont
des journées entières rouler en boule
son lit d'hôpital les rideaux tirés
le coeur au bord des lèvres en attendant
que ça se termine vivre à 40 ans c'est
me sentir peu à peu de mourir alors
après des mois d'opérations de
chimiothérapie de rayon le bout du
tunnel apparaît enfin
et je commence à remonter la pente il
est temps de recommencer à vivre à vivre
ou à être vivant
parce qu'apparemment je ne suis pas
complètement guérie dans ma tête quand
je vais mieux je retourne faire le même
travail dans la même entreprise au même
poste toxiques avec encore plus de
stress et de pression est là dans ma
tête c'est le déclic
de l'extérieur les circonstances sont
les mêmes mais à l'intérieur tout est
différent
pourquoi les épreuves de ces derniers
mois ont fait prendre conscience de ce
qui est essentiel
mes choix sont différents je n'accepte
plus ce qui est toxique pour moi alors
je renonce à cette promotion et je
charge de travail mon cancer m'a rendu
la vie
alors pourquoi est-ce que je suis devant
vous aujourd'hui parce que je souhaite à
chacun d'entre nous de vivre de vivre
vraiment de vivre maintenant
aujourd'hui je voudrais être votre
thérapie sans avoir besoin d'aller
jusqu'à la maladie et je veux vous
demander
vivre c'est quoi pour vous comment est
ce que vous vivez
qu'est ce qui vous rend vivant - ce qui
le rend vivant aujourd'hui c'est de
prendre du temps de me relâcher de
m'apaiser comme le dit serge bianchi il
est urgent de ralentir de faire des
choses qui nous font du bien qui nous
donne de la force qui nous remplissent
de l'intérieur oublions un peu nos
obligations soyons égoïste apprenons à
dire non que ce soit nos enfants à notre
conjoint à notre travail à nos amis
apprenons à dire non parce que nous
sentons que nos limites sont atteintes
entourons nous de personnes positives
bienveillante qui nous font du bien
essayant de mettre notre esprit au repos
est ce que vous connaissez pense ouvrir
le hamster non c'est une petite bête qui
court dans sa roue à l'intérieur de
notre tête qui nous rend la vie dure et
parfois vous empêche même de dormir
derrière le tapage incessant de pan
souillard se cache notre ego il nous
fait souffrir
il nous leurs ils nous empêchent d'être
libre alors observant un peu ses
mouvements amusons-nous de ses pitreries
plus ralentissons pour finalement
trouver la paix cessons de revenus et 7
bis qui obscurcit tout pensé laissant la
terre retombé au fond et l'eau claire
remonter à la surface
car oui nous avons besoin d'avoir les
idées claires pour prendre conscience de
ce qui est essentiel pour nous pour nous
reconnecter à nos racines pour prendre
les bonnes décisions et vivre alors
aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs
j'aimerais vous donner un petit
traitement une petite prescription
prenez une bonne dose de méditation
quotidienne 20 minutes de yoga après le
repas un soupçon de relaxation de la
marche hebdomadaire et une semaine de
jeûne annuel horreur auto ressources non
ce sont là mes traitements réguliers car
se reconnecter à sont moins profonds
lâcher prise prendre conscience de ses
priorités et osé choisir ce qui est le
mieux pour nous c'est ça la définition
de vivre l'ignorons pas notre besoin de
vibrer de nous dépasser de nous élever
nous en avons besoin
le monde en a besoin
arrêtons de ressasser le passé le futur
les prochaines vacances
la prochaine fois vivent ici et
maintenant et comme disait oscar wilde
vivre c'est la chose de plus rares du
monde
la plupart des gens se contentent
d'exister il nous contentons plus
d'exister d'être spectateur prenons les
bonnes décisions faisant les bons choix
et vivant merci
[Applaudissements]